hello guys my name is the churner
welcome back to my damaged
series so last time we talked about
shaders and we made them into asset
files check out that video you can have
it already and today we're gonna be
continuing on with our shader journey
making our shader API and library a
little bit more robust a little bit more
powerful because of course traders are
pretty much the basis of all the
graphics programming we'll be doing so
they're gonna be taking a look at shader
libraries that I mentioned last time
briefly basically shader libraries are
just it's a way for us to literally
stall to store all of our shaders inside
a library so instead of just kind of
creating a shader and then having to
deal having that burden of ownership on
ourselves meaning that like okay well
we've you know we need to store it like
in a member phungster is a member or we
need to pass it around certain functions
or we need to make sure that you know we
need we have like our Saanich adder that
we want to render inside our mesh class
for example but we also want to in
sandbox we also might want it elsewhere
in our code base instead of us having to
do that and instead of us actually like
forcing the user of the engine to deal
with that themselves we're going to make
we're going to basically write a system
in hazal to deal with that for us so
that we don't have to do that I think
that in general it's good to have a
robust engine API that provides the user
of the engine so like the client
application as many kind of as much help
really as possible because if you're
kind of writing an engine and it's kind
of doing half of the job it's not
providing a complete library to the user
to actually be able to do a lot of these
common tasks then it's just it's just
not as good as it could be because you
have to think about it this way right
we've written this little engine called
hazel and it's gonna be used presumably
by a number of games to actually make
those games so by us kind of drawing the
line and saying that nor this kind of
feature must be implemented by the user
right who is who is that user you need
to think about who that actual target
audience is well presumably someone
using hazel is going to be some
who is probably not an engine programmer
right I mean if they're an engine
programmer likely they're going to
either write their own engine or maybe
like they would know enough about engine
architecture and all of that to not even
be relevant to this conversation but
most likely it's been be someone who's
one who wants to actually use the engine
the vast majority of game developers out
there are not engine programmers and so
because of that especially nowadays
especially with with with kind of both
unity and unreal making it super easy to
write games right you don't need to
worry about anything really
c-sharp will kind of take care of itself
in unity and then blueprints and unreal
will kind of do all of the heavy lifting
for you anyway of course you might have
to write custom C++ or whatever that's
besides the point the point is if you
make a beauty make a game without that
and with hazel as well we will have a
scripting language so eventually I guess
my point is that it's gonna be really
easy to make games and hazel so suddenly
if you're kind of burdened with this
kind of like okay it's really easy to
make a game and hazel but if I want to
do something with shaders which you
might own which you might not even have
to touch right like I made shaders
shaders you shouldn't have to do
anything with shaders if you want to
make a game in hazel oh that's kind of
you should just be able to draw
something on the screen without touching
a shader let's say you're a little bit
more advanced you want to maybe write
your own shader you want to kind of get
into that land right just like unity
lets you as well but then you have to
have this shader library that you have
to you have to kind of handle that stuff
yourself now what's what's gonna happen
from that is that a number of people are
probably going to not know how to do
this properly or not know how to do this
well and they're gonna write a solution
that isn't as optimal as something that
we could kind of think about and design
and create right now so what that's
going to in turn produce for hazel is
basically it's just gonna make the
engine run worse it might be more
error-prone might have more bugs it
might just be slower in terms of
performance it might not be perfect
right because that is kind of a core
system that we want to actually design
ourselves because we have kind of
quality control over that and then if
someone who uses this again if we don't
call that talked about like something
called the pit of success
which is basically the fact that no
matter what you do you should fall into
that pit of success meaning that if
someone just completely misuses this API
and just write something completely
garbage or just just doesn't know how to
use it and so they don't do half of the
stuff the engine should still more or
less succeed in giving them something
that's actually not like the worst thing
in the world right you shouldn't be able
to put hazel into a state where it's
just like a crash zone that's not water
she should be easy right it should be
easy it should be robust you should just
work that's kind of the the goal I guess
of this engine and probably most
software projects that any of you guys
should be working on but my point here
is that since that's provided for you
since that shader library is provided
for you you can just kind of use that
and of course you can still write your
own as the user feel like I don't want
this I want to work differently if you
know what you're doing that's fine
still want to give so when someone hazel
to kind of provide that control to
people but it's there if you want to use
it and it's kind of the right way to do
things and that's kind of why it's
important to it
take a step back think about these
things as if you're kind of designing
your engine and just um yeah just do as
much work as possible for your users for
your clients anyway before we continue
to want to give a huge thank you to all
the patrons that made this series
possible patron Tom Vall said the Cherno
you guys helped support the series
you'll get access to a private
development branch was a day in which
I've done a lot of really cool stuff and
I've also been releasing exclusive
videos just for patrons which is just
like a very casual kind of almost like a
vlog type thing where I just kind of
share my screen you know back up back up
my office and I just talk about what I'm
gonna do in the next episode of this
series and I also show off a bunch of
stuff from the Hegel development branch
it's a great way to help support this
series and to make sure these videos
continue coming out I'm actually
considering increasing the frequency of
these game engine series episodes
because as you can see like it's kind of
we just don't have enough time to get
this stuff done and like the kind of
half hour or 40 minutes that I try and
kind of make these episodes every single
week so I would like to make these
episodes twice a week so huge thank you
to everyone
does help support this stuff because
it's you guys who even make that that
possible all right anyway shader
libraries let's dive in actually before
we dive in and take a look at this kind
of stuff I do want to mention that if
you guys picked up on some things that I
wrote in the last episode that were not
not very good in terms of codes so I did
ask the question to do with STD vectors
if I was just jump in and take a look at
the code I think that might be easier if
we take a look at the OpenGL shader dual
CPP file when we wrote this code to do
with compilation we had this map that we
took in and I created this sed vector
and I used the shader sources size as a
parameter for this actual standard
vector and the reason that I did that
was because I wanted to kind of have it
I knew what size I wanted the vector and
I didn't want it to dynamically allocate
every time I push something back into it
so I thought you know what let's just do
this to resize it however upon reading
your comments and then also actually
reading the API Doc's for stem vector I
was I realized that actually that's not
what it does at all that actually
physically like creates that many
element it doesn't just resize this
storage it actually like resizes their
amount of elements that's basically the
same as calling resize instead of
reserved which is kind of what I would
after so you could fix this and in fact
if we run through this you'll see kind
of what I mean the problem is that this
actually and this will result in errors
upon disruption because what happens is
jail shader IDs already has a size of
two and it's all they're both set to
zero of course because you basically
default constructor to integers but then
when we go over here and we actually
push back what we're doing is we're
pushing back a third element and you can
see that now at the end of this and when
we actually use this stuff which is for
this kind of unlinking stuff and
detaching shader so let's go over here
by the time we get down to that line of
code this actually has four shader IDs
in it - which is zero which are garbage
so OpenGL is not gonna like the fact
that you're trying to delete stuff that
doesn't actually exist or might exist
might actually be the wrong ones
you know we're we're basically undefined
behavior because we have no idea what's
being stored at ID 0 and then 2/3 are
our ones the ones that we actually want
to detach or delete if the shedder
compilation failed so obviously this is
kind of not ideal at all to fix this
really all you would have to do is come
up here and either just get rid of the
constructor at all just so that you
don't have anything in there or if you
still want to make sure that doesn't
allocate and which is kind of what I was
going for you could just type in a
reserved and then a certain capacity
which of course will be shaded sources
outside and if we basically put a
breakpoint here and we just run this
code again and we see what we get here
you'll see that we reserved this as you
would expect the sizes until 0 the
capacities 2 which is what I was after
and then if we go all the way down to
our detachment of the shade as you can
see there's just two in there and you
have the right amount but this got me
thinking do we really need a vector for
this and the answer is no because a
vector as you guys should probably know
if you not aware of how vectors work and
how you can optimize the vectors and all
that stuff I have a few sales boss
series videos on that really important
to check those out because the thing is
a vector holds its storage dynamically
means that when we actually create this
vector it will dynamically allocate
storage for it which is fine I think
that people probably go a little bit
overboard with saying that heap
allocation czar bad I mean yes they are
bad and we are designing a game engine
so whenever we can avoid them even
though this is certainly not the worst
thing in the world I would never ever
like look at this and be like this code
cannot make it to production it's fine
and in fact it's quite nice because it
means that if we have it will work for
any number of shaders right if we have
to if we have one if we have three it's
this car is gonna work it's just gonna
work because it's a dynamically
resizable array however if we want it to
be a little bit more efficient what we
could do is actually convert this to be
a stack allocated array and you can do
that either by just using a C style
array or we can just use STD array which
is what I'm gonna do right now the
downside to that and look
I mean if you you could still
technically keep that dynamic size if
you wanted to what you could do is and
by dynamic size I'm not actually talking
about the ability to resize because
there isn't there shouldn't ever be an
ability to resize really for this
because if you think about it shader
sources we're taking in an unordered map
we know how big everything years we do
it's it's we know that it's gonna be to
shade as a vertex and fragment shadow
right now because we obviously know
about this because we're compiling the
shaders now we know how many there are
however we do we don't know that until
runtime we don't know right now at in
terms of like compile time how how many
shaders we actually have and in in the
c++ if you want to have a stack
allocated array we need to know that
stack size up front so in other words if
i make an array right now i have to say
i want an array of size two for example
i can't be like i'll just have an array
of sized shader sources dot size that's
the dynamic runtime variable we don't
know that data until runtime it just
needs to be known at compile time
however there is a way around that you
could use a function called alakay what
that does and i think i use that in the
opengl series episode basically what
that does is it performs a stack
allocation it's like a malloc with the
heap allocation except it does it on it
it does it on the stack now it leads
it's got a few differences I don't this
videos not gonna be about allocate but
it does have a few differences such as
the fact that for example unlike stack
allocations the scope of that allocation
is discovered the function of the scarp
that you're in which in this case if we
allocated it well we did with the vector
would be the same as the function scope
but also some people claim that it
doesn't it reduces to become it means
that the compiler can't optimize things
as well and that's I don't know I
haven't personally run into any issues
with that so I would say go ahead is
probably gonna be better than this
solution but because we don't really
need to resort to allocate it's not like
the difference is gonna be we might have
one shader we might have 15 we might
have a thousand it's not like that at
all we basically are either gonna have
two shaders maybe three shaders maybe if
it's a computer we have one the point is
that the variance is so slow so low and
these are GL enums if
take a look at what Jill Imam actually
is it's an unsigned e it's a 32-bit
integer however a 32-bit integer I'm not
gonna have I'm not gonna cry about if we
have like a basically four bytes of
storage so one integer or if we have 12
bytes because we have three that's
absolutely insignificant and it's gonna
be way faster for us to allocate that on
the stack and have too many so for
example let's just get 12 bytes of stack
allocated storage because that's three
shaders right 3d nums three unsigned
integers it's a lot better for us to
just request 12 bytes from the stack
it's literally like like you wrote three
integers in your source code like you
have a full loop that's one integer
right maybe you have three full loops
and just the indices that's three digits
that's done right you don't think about
that stuff but when you're making arrays
it's tempting to be like nah it's too
big or that's too small or whatever but
my point is that if we just write some
code here that says I want to allocate a
stack array that has three integers or
voyageurs or ten integers that is still
going to be a lot faster than if we
create this vector and then it does a
heap allocation and it only allocates
not a nerd to the integers worth or you
know how many it needs so you shouldn't
be worrying about that stuff let's just
convert this into an array because
that's what it really should be it
should just be a stack allocated array
so what I'll do is I'll include that
because I don't think I'm not sure if we
have that in the PCH we really should
I'll include that in the PCH here so
we'll have array
my recommendation with this kind of
stuff is try and use array whenever you
can of a vector because using the
vectors liberally is not a very good
thing to do because of the hip
allegations and of course since we are
kind of making an engine it's really
good to think about that kind of stuff
so what we'll do is basically what we'll
have is a city array we'll have GL enum
and what I'm gonna do right now is
actually write true for the size now
this might be controversial so to speak
because as I just mentioned we could
have three shaders a bit of one whatever
right we basically need this number to
be the maximum number of shaders ever
and to make sure that we never you know
don't do our job correctly we're gonna
make a coarser here the base
says that data sources has to be less
than or equal to two okay because if
it's not if it's three for example this
code is not going to work correctly at
all so that's what we'll do then we'll
be able just say that you know I don't
know I am you know what to write up all
message basically the only we only
support true shaders for now or
something like that I'm the owner I'll
get rid of the inflammation markers it's
really not that exciting okay cool so
basically we'll just do something like
this and of course it's gonna be shader
sources sighs we're creating two of
these here we get rid of this completely
and now we need some kind of ID or index
for them so the easiest way to kind of
deal with this is just to make a little
hint which is just gonna be our gel
shader ID index or something like that
all right we'll set this equal to zero
and then every time we use it we just
increment it so over here in jail shader
IDs we just do share our ideas girl
shader ID index plus plus so we do a
post increment because of course we do
want to actually use it at like the
value zero first and then next time we
run it it'll be one right that has to be
that size and then we basically don't
need to use it ever again right so
that's kind of it because over here of
course we just we can iterate through it
as normal so what we've done is we've
converted it to be a staff allocate an
array we're just storing eight bytes on
the stack now instead of eight bytes on
the heap which is gonna be a lot faster
especially like the allocation stage not
to mention that technically whilst I
would probably we are using a lot of
stuff here you might expect the sed
vector to have its stuff ready to go in
the CPU cache but it might not be where
is this definitely will because it's on
the stack it's really hot and readily
accessible memory which is what we want
anyway um yeah this will work as
expected I might be the only test that
it's definitely gonna work but if we
look over here when we detach them for
example you can see that we have all of
that stuff in there and of course when
that gets destroyed we don't need to
free anything from the heap either it's
all kind of just part of this stack that
belongs to this function okay cool so
that was just something that I wanted to
there was actually one other thing that
I wrote that was incorrect very easy to
make this mistake or if we look over at
the file reading source code basically
what we had here was I used STD iOS in
and then I wrote a comma instead of a an
org device all operator because this is
actually all one parameter this is a
bunch of bit flies it says what kind of
input stream this is in meaning that
we're opening the file as an input
stream submitting read-only and then sed
iOS binary meaning we're going to be
reading it as a binary if you I don't
even know what that other it just says
in prod like I'm not sure what that is
actually did look at the API here I
didn't even find a third parameter to be
honest all of these things have just two
parameters so I'm not really sure what
that does but anyway as you can see all
of the modes all the applicable modes
here it's a bit masked type so you can
all them together of course and we have
in which is open for reading and then we
have binary which is open in a binary
merge okay so that stuff is fixed up now
that we've fixed up all of our code from
last time we've kind of discussed why
you needed fixing and especially like I
really wanted to mention that kind of
vector array thing because I feel like
that comes up all the time we can
finally get into our shader library so
this is going to be very simple
basically what this is going to be
something that's owned by the renderer
essentially and that's good because it
enables us to automatically load all
about default shaders all about kind of
vital necessary shaders which might
include like diagnostic shaders for
example we can load all that all of that
stuff up when the renderer initializes
and then we can you know they'll be
readily available in our program and if
the client or if the user wants to like
alert additional stuff that they're more
than welcome to do that that will just
work and of course because it will be
kind of awed by the renderer it'll be
all static which means that you can
access it anyway in your code base so
let's just dive in and write that code
so what I'll do is I'll go to just
normal shader h-file so all the shadow
related stuff is going to be in this
file I'm not going to create a bunch of
files that are basically all going to be
to do with shaders and call them like
shader library or H I think that's just
gonna make the readability kind of
difficult and just having extra files is
never a great yeah so what we'll do is
underneath shader will make all right
possible skater library and the core to
all of this so we'll have we don't even
really need to have constructors of
these structures I think the core of all
of this is going to be an unordered map
of string through a Hazel reference of a
shader right so this will be our shaders
and I only include our unordered map
okay that's gonna be basically all that
this shader library is and then we'll
have a nice API to make it really easily
accessible so we'll have an odd function
which just takes in a shader so that we
can add a shader that it kind of exists
already into there so we'll just say
Const RAF shader
isn't the reason I take the tin as a
Const reference by the way is because
the copy we don't really need to worry
about copying this it'll get copied the
actual smart point will get copied when
we go into the unordered map that's at
which point we kind of copy us so we're
gonna bleeding to you know make an extra
kind of rep count here for no reason
that's why I like doing it this way
because I think the back comes up as
well sometimes so we can load a shader
just straight up because that would be
kind of convenient I think and this
should just return a rack just in case
we want it so the load will basically
take in a file path so cons STDs string
file path and then what we'll do
optionally is will allow will allow
people to just kind of name the shaders
as well so by default the name that
that's gonna exist is if we have a
shader like textured or GLSL by default
is going to store it as texture so in a
stripped extension strip default path
any kind of directories that we might
have
assets or whatever I'll strip that and
we'll just get that texture name out and
matter that's what the name will be and
that's what this string is this string
is going to be a unique name which
identifies our shader and then that of
course is going to be the shader pointer
to support this naming so we will have
to actually add some self true the
shader API because of course at the
moment if you add something with just a
shader you know I don't want users tough
to specified names or anything like that
and then we'll have to have some kind of
get function of course we'll have wrap
shader guess and then this will just
basically retrieve something from that
unordered map by just the name it just
like that that's our entire API let's go
ahead and create all that stuff using
the visual assist who I am NOT sponsored
by by the way is your one room but if
they would like to sponsor me I'm of
course ready
so really the add function is just what
it needs to do is get the name of the
shader out so basically something like
share to get name this doesn't exist yet
but we need to add that once this got it
is going to need to check to make sure
the map doesn't already have a shader
with that name because if it does and
you know the shader is already present
we can't use that and then otherwise of
course if it doesn't so I'm just writing
some pseudo code here then we basically
just write basically to store it so
we'll say I'm shaders name equals share
just like that so the biggest thing
right now is we need to somehow get that
name out of that shader file class so if
we go to share it or age not everything
has a name and that's probably fine what
we can do is when we create a shader
pair like this we can mandate to have a
name so we'll say Const STD string name
that's probably a good thing to do
because now that we're kind of storing
these things as actual like inside a
shader library it makes sense that every
kind of asset should have some kind of
ID now you could of course just store
this as an ID that's totally fine but
the problem is we want people to be able
to access that and if it humans
strings are the way to go so that's why
we're using strings here this is totally
fine as well and then what I'll do is
just make a virtual SC
string it'll be a contest a string so
I'll make a shadow store it get a name
and then Constable's equals zero okay so
that's gonna be our function so grab
that
I'll grab all of it and I'll go to jail
shader the H and then over here maybe
somewhere around yeah I will just do a
Const override this will just return a
mean name which is something that
traders will now store so over here at
city spring em name and then if we come
over here actually what I'll do is I'll
add name here just like that and then if
we go into our source code I mean it's
all source code but but I meant the dot
CPP file so we'll have a name here and M
name name okay that looks pretty good to
me and then here we actually need to
extract that name from the file pot so
it's kind of easy to do all we really
need to do is and I'm just thinking I
might do this after everything gets
compiled successfully it doesn't really
matter there what I basically do is just
do some basic string operations on that
file path to get that stuff so the first
thing that I'm interested in is getting
the last slash out when you're doing
stuff like this it's really nice to just
be able to kind of write an example for
yourself so you can actually see what's
going on so we've had assets shaders
text about GLSL that's kind of what
we're looking at and we need to selected
this so if you think about it what we
need is that last slash right and then
the last kind of will the last from the
end that last dot so if we had like
textured oh I don't know intentional
shaded or jail cell we would want to
probably select this right because
that's part of the file name and then
the last dot followed by some letters is
the kind of extension of our file so if
we have something like this
the last slash we can get really easily
or we all we need to do is just use the
file name or file path dots
find the last of
make sure you use last toggle not last
not off and then we can actually add a
string here because the other thing you
have to think about is on Windows
someone could actually use a backslash
right so we need to handle that as well
so we'll just do fine last off full
slash or a backslash so once we have
that we'll need to just make sure that
actually exists as well because if you
think about it if we just have that
there is no slash at all and that means
the last slice will be equal to s to D
string and class which means it wasn't
found so in that scenario if it is
embossed we just want to set it to zero
otherwise we want to set it to last
slash last one and the reason we want to
do plus one is because if we don't do
plus one then we'll have it'll just be
the beginning index of course of this
it'll be the index of the slash which is
here not over here and we want it to be
one past that so that's how we get our
last lash
the last dot thing is also quite easy to
get all we need to do is do file paths
we could just do find the last of as
well but there is another function
called our find it's basically the same
as line last off with bone loss stuff
will actually try and find any of the
characters you give in your string
whereas I'll find will kind of match it
exactly and we just need to find a dot
so it's better for us to use it in this
case and then once we do find that last
dot I want to use a function called so
we'll use file path del substring a
function call substring and what that
takes is an offset and account not an
officer not kind of a beginning and an
end index so because of that we can't
just use this but actually you should
work out what the count is so the count
will just be now the count of course
depending on whether or not we do we
even have a dot because totally a file
doesn't have to have an extension so in
that case if there is no exception so
last dot doesn't exist rice the last R
equals s D string and cause in that case
we'll just use file pop sighs - that
last slash so we're basically again if I
bring back everything over here assets
shaders texture what we're basically
doing is if if it's if it's not found so
there is no dot at all we're just so
that would look like this
we're basically just saying in the count
here's the file pastel sighs - lost
slash so this is last lashes file sizes
so if we
back which is selecting this many
characters which in this case would be
seven which is exactly what we want
however if we do have a dot like we do
here we're basically to go from the dot
to the slash and that's our count
because we're gonna we're gonna start
this file path or substring we're gonna
start that at last slash right because
that's kind of here and of course we did
we said last last a lot / + 1 so it'll
be perfect and then we want to basically
measure from that last dot to that last
slash how many characters that we have
so that simply becomes last dot minus
last slash and then that's it we can
just put that count in and we have our
name just like that okay so this
basically is through extract name on
file month okay cool
done that's all you have to do and we of
course need to test this so what I'll do
is just put a breakpoint in here and hit
f5 and of course I forgot that we just
multiply this whole API which is gonna
wreck everything so what I'll do is just
fix up all of the API changes of amazing
we have file path over here sorry we had
a name so we taking a name now if we
create is like that so that's actually
gonna require a bit of a refactor but
that's fine it needed to be done let's
see what else we have
so array Lord okay this stuff needs to
return stuff we have get name now so we
can actually finish writing the shader
library and let's will test the name
stuff at the end so I just want to add a
corset here which basically just
verifies that that M shade is still find
that our map doesn't actually contain
that shadow already so if that doesn't
equal M shadows dot M right that means
that we actually have that inside the
map already so we'll say shader already
exists okay and then that way we know
that we're trying to add something twice
for Lord so this is a file path it takes
in a shader and lo so this is kind of
easy as well all we need to do is say
water shader equals shader create and
then of possible taking a file path then
we'll have a name so we'll grab this and
we can actually just through add with
that shader once we have that and then
once we've added a shader like that so
this family still takes a pointer I
thought we changed this stuff I guess we
didn't that's actually weird maybe I
accidentally I'm not synched up the
repository correctly or maybe we didn't
in which case we didn't if we didn't we
just needed to change this stuff to be a
ref I'm not a pointer so that's the kind
of easy to do I think there might be
some areas in which we forgot to do that
and then this becomes I'm fairly sure we
did this but again I don't remember 100
Sam Choy's and that we didn't sir make
shared I'm Kirk in jail shade up um it
doesn't matter if we already did this
and that's fine as well but it's the
same what's that not copy correctly at
all make sure to let me know that I get
cold so that looks pretty good to me
so now we just do a kata and then we can
just return the shadow because that's
what load once so we basically create it
and then we're at it in the maratona so
lord with a name specifically he's gonna
do the same thing it's just that instead
of us adding it using the add function
like at that what we actually have to do
is add it by name just wondering it's
probably better to make a movies because
we want so that's maybe if we're taking
a file path what we want to give it a
custom name that's fine as well I guess
what I'll do is I'll actually make
another version of this that takes in a
name and it's
gonna be the same thing as the other one
so we'll grab populace so that we can
implement it ourselves and then what
I'll do is so this will kind of be the I
guess the the super ones will actually
put it ahead because we'll get this ad
to call that out so what this will do is
I'll copy this it's just the difficult
name so we don't have to worry about
getting the name out of the shader at
all so it's got a name and then this
will basically just call add we've met
with the name that it got an initiator
so this way we support adding adding it
without a name of queer and have a name
or rather we support adding it with a
custom name instead of relying on the
file name if that's what you want and
then finally get will be super easy
basically we'll just return em shaders
name but we should assert of course to
make sure that it exists so we'll say
that shader okay this is wrong actually
so and I missed that so we're trying to
make sure that it does equal and right
so that means that we do not find the
shader in this case we want to assert
that it's not end which means that we do
find the shader so if that actually
assessed been stated or found and then
that's it okay we don't want to waste
time really doing stuff like if you know
handling it and maybe returning like a
null pointer you could do stuff like
that
but the problem is that businessart will
be stripped out in release mode you
probably should never have a state in
which you request a shader and then it's
not found if that's really like an issue
we could easily add a function that you
know that has something like exists
shadow library dot you know exists and
then just a name and then in that case
what this will do and make this constant
what that would do is just
if I implemented quickly and then all
that this could do is just return em
chatters find name doesn't equal em
chatters ends so if it doesn't eat land
then it does exist and that returns true
which is what we want and of course
since you've written this code you can
of course just do exists and then name
to make sure that it actually you're
asserting that it does exist and then in
this case we'll replace this with
doesn't exist so not exists name just
like that okay cool and now we have a
pretty functional shader library so
where does this deserve to live
technically speaking it should be
something owned by the renderer as you
can see we're in a situation here what
we don't even have storage for the
renderer so I'll show you how it works
in sandbox and then when we actually get
into how the renderer is going to store
all of its variables which we haven't
even covered yet that's when we'll kind
of deal with that so yeah I think I know
what happened here I am on a I must be
on
I don't know everything's fine but these
are all yeah I was so sure that we
replaced this stuff I met I may be on an
old copy because what I did
stupidly is I kind of mute to my
repository because I thought I committed
it but I didn't so I lost all of my
local changes and that might have
included fixing stuff from last episode
so if that's happened then I'm sorry
so this shader I don't even know what
this is I don't think we are we using
this anyway anyway I am shader we were
using it for our triangle so I'll kind
of I'll kind of call it our triangle
shader see this is good because it
forces us to actually call a shader
something so we'll say vertex color
triangle maybe because you can see that
if you look at the source code he kind
of has that color to be based on the
vertex positions so you know vertex may
be vertex position vertex positive color
okay so that's that shader and in this
shader with black color shader
other names that flash color and I think
everything else is good let's try and
compile this card and see what happens
we still have a few errors inside the
urban GL shader stuff which is probably
too fine I may have just forgotten to do
some things so what's actually wrong
with this thing about overloaded
operators M name that should be okay not
sure why it's complaining notices of
overloaded function every judge try to
match it matches so alright okay so i
accidentally removed com2 yeah that was
probably riddles you here because
sometimes when you type stuff it likes
to remove words around what you're
typing it's really frustrating I should
turn it off but anyway um well here are
five and we'll see what this gives us
okay cool so everything's kind of
working one thing that I did want to
check was whether or not that name was
trips successfully so if we just look at
this break point and we look at
everything else here the name should be
set it's just texture as you can see it
was just perfect it's exactly what we
want okay great so now to use this
shredder library what you need to do is
and this will be done in this will be
done eventually of course in our actual
renderer so this is not something that
you would do in sandbox basically we
include shader
I think every child care to include
shader so we actually don't need to need
to even include this we basically set up
a shader library so again really easy to
do that and it can totally leave on the
stack so just shade a library just like
that and then what we need to do is
every time we add a shader instead of
having to worry about holding references
to it and of course this is a haze
little shader library instead of
worrying about holding references to it
like this you can see we've got like M
shaded here for example we don't really
need to worry about that at all
for our texture shaders which is just as
an example let's just get rid of that
texture shader so let's see what we had
here initially because we definitely had
so we had our texture shadow where is
that it's over here let's get rid of it
so I'll show you guys kind of how like
what this actually does so instead of
having amped extra chatter what we
really need to do is just do em share
shared library and then we can just do
large with just a file pod so we just
kind of end up with something like this
I'm sure the library Lord and then if we
actually want to access it like we do
here the Lord actually returns a rap so
we're going to say order you know
texture data or something like this if
we want it to we put that we put that in
here and then that's fine because that
reference will die and that's totally
okay what happens is when we needed our
here to render stuff we just say order
texture shader equals M shader library
don't yet and then a texture just like
that and then we just replace this like
this so what does now gives us is the
ability to actually store everything
inside a shader library and then
reference it as we need true now in this
case it's kind of a step backwards
because instead of having a nice
reference inside sandbox app and just
being able to render that and not have
to worry about getting stuff out of an
unordered map even though that is super
fast instead of doing that and instead
of having a member what kind of resorted
to doing this stuff which is kind of not
the best thing to do in this case but of
course you have to imagine the fact that
you're not going to have everything in
one file in this one kind of example
layer yeah example layer so instead of
having all this stuff here you'll have
it a whole round you're kind of engine
code and all around your gang code and
then now what we've done is a way to
access this and of course you instead of
having shader library we might have
something like a renderer a shader
library and then yeah just like that
so it would be a little bit more static
and a little bit more accessible than
having to have something like this but
you can see it works like this as well
so if you really wanted to have
segregated shader libraries of just
various groups or chunks of shaders you
can do that as well we should probably
test this make sure it works if we get
f5 then we should see that in action and
you can see we get exactly the same
as before so in a nutshell Danny's
shredder libraries that's how they work
I'm not gonna go ahead and replace every
shader where we have with that specific
like shadow library version of that
shader because that's for this example
it's not necessary probably wouldn't use
it but when we do have like a standard
kind of 2d shader or a standard like I
don't know blur shade or some
post-processing shader and it's standard
like PBR shader in that kind of case
that's when you actually would want to
use the shader library you would have
you have the renderer upon
initialization actually load the load
all those required assets and resources
like the PBR shader that it uses for
example and then that would actually
store it in the shader library so that
is accessible by your entire code base
and that's actually what hazel dev does
at them at the moment anyway I hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did hit
that like button as mentioned earlier
you can help support everything that I
do here on YouTube by going to patreon
Akhilesh at the Turner huge thank you to
everyone who is graciously supporting
this series next time look there's so
many things that we have to think about
I actually want to have a bit of a
maintenance episode I might might have
it is like a midweek thing we'll see if
I get the chance true just because there
are a few things we need to kind of
clean up here and I want to deal with
the repository a little bit as well so
we will see but apart from that yeah
well we might have like we are
gravitating towards 2d so I think the
very very soon will start kind of
building up everything we need to get a
nice tuna renderer into here I'll see
you guys later goodbye
[Music]